schlechte Nachrichten für alle Twitter
Freaks Nora chirner twittert nicht warum
sie hat ein Leben sagt sie warum man
dann nicht twittern kann das jetzt im
Fragenlotto und noch ganz viele andere
gemeine Fragen an Sie also viel
spaßose genau pass auf die roten sind
mit grundrot das sind gemeine Fragen und
die Grünen sind hab
fragen rot hast du gesagt wenn du SST di
mit
Grund oh
autsch warum arbeitest du jetzt als ein
kronsprecherin keine Rollenangebote mehr
das ist richtig und Disney zahlt sehr
gut also ihr seid ja wohl auch besonders
ge sind jetzt alles so diese Leute die
man die Foren schreiben und denken ja
das ist inspiriert durch das Internet
geil und euch W schon mal Fragen
beantworten ihr Klöpse also pass auf
Mäuschen jetzt geht's weiter Mäuschen
mein ich übrigens nicht dich also will
ich auch hoffen
apropos bereust du oft was du ein
Interview
[Musik]
sagst nein vielleicht man man weiß nicht
was interessiert dich mein Geschwätz von
gestern was interessiert dich mein
Geschwätz von gestern ist auch geil was
interessiert es uns alle man weiß es
nicht ja das könnt ihr euch das könnt
euch gar nicht me vorstellende Welt ohne
das was twitterst du so den ganzen Tag
Leute das könnt ihr nicht verstehen aber
ich ich habe ein
Leben denk mal drüber
nach aber du hast mehrere Twitter
Account ja ich habe mehrere Twitter
Accounts danke dafür wer auch immer das
macht und Sachen schreibt
wie kalt im Winter nee ich twittere
nicht ich werde wahrscheinlich
irgendwann mal twittern wenn es um
Projekt geht oder wenn man so eine Band
hat oder S finde ich das cool als
Einzelperson kann ich das irgendwie noch
nicht ich bin ja auch nicht so eloquent
und so na ja nicht ganz so eloquent ne
ich will no eine rote kannst auch grüne
gerne noch ziehen was wenn da vielleicht
sind vielleicht habt ihrich heute
vertauscht nein die haben wir nicht
vertauscht die sind schon entschuldig
mal hier ist dein erstes
Haustier siehst du das ist sowas kann
man kann die grün nicht aufmach das kann
man nicht me Antworten auch schwierig
gut das hö ich oft außer von den Leuten
die die Zettel schreiben woher hast du
deine sympathische
Ausstrahlung n wiserweise froh dass
diese anonyme Person mir diese Frage
stellt darüber wollte ich schon immer
mal gerne ein Referat halten es war
nicht
leicht schlimm ist gegangen in meinem
Leben aber ich bin immer Mensch
geblieben und
hab einfach gedacht behandle andere auch
so wie du
selber super gerührt von mir jetzt
gerade aber du ich weiß das nicht ist
geil ne ich weiß das nicht es ist
einfach passiert ich bin einfach ein
Hammer Sympath kannst du kannst du
halten kannst du drehen und wenn wie du
will ist so ist einfach natürlich
wahnsinnig gut gelaufen für euch ne dass
ihr mich sehen dürft super und noch mehr
Fragen Lotos gibt es bei klickum unter
anderem das mit apme Reloaded die
erklären ob Sie nur eine schlechte
smosch Kopie sind wen das interessiert
dieses Video anklicken oder auch darum
bei uns im Fragenlotto die die
hochnpeinliche Frage beantworten muss
warum bist du so schön den Grund erfahrt
er im Fragenlotto mit ihr
also und ansonsten ja genau bis dann
bleib
dran